[Music]
kim kardashian is supporting her ex
kanye west the best way she knows how
through fashion yep despite kamye's
ongoing court proceedings to finalize
their divorce kim still got her exes
back in a surprising way just something
for my heart the beauty mogul did just
that snapping these pics with their
daughters north in chicago west to
support yay's futuristic yeezy sunglass
launch
talk about fashion forward nine-year-old
north strikes a pose in her dad's silver
sunnies
and four-year-old shai is serving a mini
supermodel in the making effortlessly
posing next to her mom kim
judging from the cute pigs this line of
yeezys should be a hit with loyal yay
fans and the launch is already creating
a buzz with all the fashion lovers i'm
glad that it was really well received as
for kim and kanye's relationship it
seems to be turning a corner after some
ups and downs since calling it quits
like all i can do is control how i react
to something i can't control
what other people do how he treats me
a source tells et things are cordial
between them the former couple's main
focus staying a united front for their
four kids quote kim and kanye have been
co-parenting in a healthy way lately our
source explains being a great dad has
always been very important to kanye and
his main goal is to keep his children
happy
and we're told yay is also trying to
manage his emotions better too god send
me from that crash
just so
of course we've seen the rapper react to
kim moving on and making her
relationship official with pete davidson
you just gotta roll with it according to
our e.t source kanye is making progress
quote he has been trying to keep any
intense emotions out of anything and
focus on what matters most to him which
is taking care of his family
the ex-couple's legal teams were back in
court friday as their divorce moves
forward kim's lawyer powerhouse attorney
laura wasser backed up what our source
says telling the judge kim and kanye are
getting along and are in communication
and they would like to get yay's
declaration of disclosure and close the
case
and once that's in kimye will be back to
just kim and yay we've learned this case
should be coming to a close before the
end of the year as the judge set kim and
kanye's official trial date for december
14th
[Music]